Yes.
Society as a whole.
Then you're looking at it from the wrong perspective.
Your,
your,
your level of analysis is wrong.
So you know it is society as a whole,
but what the hell good is that going to do you,
you can't complain to society as a whole.
You have to look for the micro manifestations that actually occur in your realm
and work on those.
Yeah and that's the only level of analysis you have any control over anyways.
Fix the things that are within your realm of power and what will happen as a
consequence of that is that your realm of power will grow,
but you start local because like what the hell do you know?
You're 19 or 20 or whatever it is.
Like you have,
you have a scrap with society.
It's like that's just an architectural problem.
That's all it is.
Because you don't know enough about society to have that opinion.
You know?
And I'm not being,
I'm not being a like I'm not trying to be cynical about this.
I am telling you it's an architectural problem,
you know?
Of course,
everybody who is young has a problem with society.
You're all at the bottom of the bloody dominance hierarchy unless you count the
entire rest of the world,
in which case you're already in the top 1%.
Right?
So you know,
that's where thinking about too.
So,
and you know,
if you,
if you are in involved in a battle,
in some sense with society,
you,
you're dominated by the figure of the great father,
the negative figure of the great father.
You also have to a lot of what you should do about that.
It's increased your level of gratitude.
You know,
here you are,
it's warm,
the chair works.
The floor isn't going to fall apart,
right?
You're at a prestigious institution,
you're well on your way to being one of the top 1% in society.
You're just too damn young right now for that to happen.
You're smart,
you're healthy,
you're good looking,
except for that weird thing you're wearing around your head.
So like,
you know what the hell,
it's,
everything's good for you.
So I'm,
I mean,
I know there's a tyrannical element there is,
it's real.
But,
but if that's all you see,
you're,
you're blinded and that's not good.
It'll warp you.